All we're doing is saying God made man a
certain way. He made women a certain
way.
>> I agree. But they're both human.
>> They are both human, but the man's brain
makeup was to be superior.
>> You're a Catholic. Are the people under
you inferior to you as a human?
>> You can't ask for that. I'm a little
crazy. So
>> now I got to ask you. [laughter]
>> In my mentality, any man that outranks
me is better than me. We can't make
Christ be the father cuz he never said
he was the father. Jesus and the father
are two distinct persons. I don't
believe they're the same person.
>> So why you why you debate us then?
>> Because because
>> why do you even debate us then if you
don't believe they're the same person?
>> Cuz here's the cuz that's the only thing
y'all got right.
>> So when he says of that day and hour no
man knoweth, not even the son. He
doesn't know. So the father knows
something that the son doesn't know
because the father is the most high. The
son is the son of the most high.
>> Okay. talk about
>> what what what constitutes being the
most high God
>> at the simplest definition there is no
god after that. So if we're all in it,
we're So we're the four people in this
room.
>> And if we went by rank and let's say we
get Well, I don't want to say this. I'm
gonna give it
>> to life.
>> You can give it to me.
>> No. No.
>> Look at you.
>> Hater.
>> You're not going to get me on camera.
>> And if life [laughter] is the highest,
after life there is nobody after that.
He would be the highest in this room. So
when we deal with the father, the father
for us is the most high. There is nobody
after him. Whereas when we talk about
Christ, there is somebody after Christ.
So he can't be the most high.
>> When you say after, what do you mean?
Because
>> Yeah. chronological hierarchy, power. So
if the head of every woman is the man,
the head of the man is Christ. The head
of Christ is God. After that, it's over.
>> Okay. So you say that most high is in
rank, not in nature.
>> Well, I don't think nobody has the
father's nature like that. The father is
>> You don't think Jesus has the father's
nature? That's why you have a father and
you have a son. Meaning like the father
is his own person,
>> right?
>> The son is his own person,
>> So the father the the the son is not the
person that the father is. The person
that the father is as far as spirit, as
far as obedience, as far as that, but
when you see the father, he sits on that
throne by himself. Throne.
>> I'm talking about so like I'm talking
about nature. When you bring up the
verse that you brought up about the head
of every woman is man, head of Christ is
the father, right? God the father. We we
both know that man and woman, and I said
this to you before, the man and woman,
they have the same nature as human,
right?
>> Yeah. They are they're both human.
>> So they are equal in their nature in
that way, right?
>> No.
>> So a man and a woman do not have the
same equal value as human beings.
>> No, I don't think there's no equality. I
think there's going to be men that are
greater than other men.
>> But you're talking rank still. You're
not talking
>> about power. I'm talking about
intelligence. I'm talking about like if
you put us same four of us in this room.
>> Yeah.
>> I could be the dumbest one. Life
>> could be the smartest one.
>> Right. But
>> but we're all humans.
>> Exactly. Sorry. [laughter]
>> I wish y'all could see life.
>> Would you say that life is would is a is
greater in humanity? Like has a greater
human nature than yours?
>> He could.
>> That's impossible. You guys are both
human.
>> We are. But the most high gives gifts to
every man differently.
>> Yes. That has nothing to do with your
nature though.
>> Base level, we all have arms, legs,
eyes,
>> ears, human, nose, human DNA. So at the
base level, yes. Going to the gifts, the
most high give those gifts. So I'm more
so speaking from that lens, right?
>> But a man and a woman are not the same.
>> As far as what?
>> As far as their makeup. A woman was made
inferior to man.
>> I I disagree because both of both the
man and the woman was made in the image
of God and they're both human being. How
is the woman made inferior? And I'm I'm
not talking rank, not talking her role
is to submit to the man. Her essence,
her human nature, you're saying is
inferior to the
>> she wasn't made to be equal to a man.
The image of the
>> We got to make sure we get it together.
>> I'm talking about in her physical
makeup.
>> Sorry. Okay. her biology, her her phys
her physiology, I think that's a word,
her physiology. When it talks about in
the image of God, it's talking about our
ability. What separates us from an
animal is the ability to receive
instructions, the ability to keep the
law, the ability to obey, the ability to
stop or go like that. That's the image.
So when woman was created, she was
created with a certain set of abilities.
When a man was created, he was created
with a certain set of abilities. Right?
>> The man's abilities are stronger than
the woman's
>> physically,
>> right? That's what I'm saying. So, I'm
not when I'm saying weak, just for the
audience sake, I'm not saying she's
weak, period. Because you can read in
the Bible that the strongest thing on
the planet is a woman because of our
desire for the woman. The man is first,
the woman is second in their core.
>> So, but so all all you're doing is
saying that a man is physically stronger
than a woman.
>> That a man was made to stronger than a
woman. And so, but okay. Would you say
that a a woman was made more nurturing
than a man?
>> Yes.
>> So, would a man be inferior to the woman
in that way?
>> No, he wouldn't be inferior because he
was never given that capability.
>> Exactly. So, so when we're when we're
all we're doing is saying God made man a
certain way, he made women a certain
way.
>> I agree.
>> Uh there's certain advantages that men
have, there's certain advantages that
women have, but they're both human.
>> They are both human. But when man was
created, he was created to be the leader
of a woman.
>> That's rank now.
>> No, no, no, no. What I'm What I'm saying
is their brain makeup.
>> You're a captain,
>> right?
>> Are the people under you inferior to you
as a human?
>> You can't ask for that. I'm a little
crazy. So,
>> now I got to ask you [laughter]
>> in my mentality, any man that outranks
me is better than me spiritually. Is
better than me. the way he was made, the
way God gave him something that he did
not give me. So that's how I look at
life. So I look at that because that
allows me to now listen to this person
because in our organization, our rank
doesn't come from a man giving me the
rank. Our rank comes from the most high
giving that rank. So we don't have a
time served type of rank like ours comes
directly from the most high. The most
high put somebody to outrank me. the
Lord saw something in them that he
didn't see in me. Doesn't mean that I'm
less of a man like in my household, in
my way of life or anything like that,
but he just Right. But he just has
something that I don't have.
>> Okay. So, that's where we're at. Uh a a
man who's ranked higher than you, who
God has called to a higher role than
than yours doesn't mean that you are
inferior as a man.
>> Not as a man. No.
>> Okay. And so, because you guys have the
same nature,
>> right?
>> So, that's what I'm saying. Like rank
and nature are two different things. You
could be higher in rank, but that
doesn't mean that you are now inferior
by nature simply because of a somebody
has a higher role.
>> Yeah. And and so that's why when we talk
about the most high and Christ, the most
high is separate from Christ.
>> Distinct.
>> Same thing.
>> No, no, there's a difference.
>> Okay. The most high has a throne he sits
on. Christ presents before that throne.
He's walking to the throne. He's
separated from him. Not let me see if
you I think. So when I say separate, you
think because they're not on the same
That's not what I'm talking about now.
>> Okay.
>> What I'm talking about is the Most High
has his own body. Is that fair enough?
Christ has his own body.
>> The the Most High, the Father has his
own person. The Son has his own person,
>> right? And they're separate. What from
the conversation we're talking about?
>> Distinct. There's a difference between
>> Now you see how you won't separate them
because that's the I think that's the
same thing I'm doing when I'm explaining
mine because you agreed that they're two
different entities.
>> But the reason why you won't do separate
is because you believe that they're on
the same accord.
>> They're it's because I believe they have
the they share the exact same essence in
nature. So like they're they're not
they're they're not separate by time and
space and like they're they're and see
that's that's the thing. So from my
position,
>> right,
>> the father and the son
>> coexist co-eternal.
>> So there was a time where
>> there was never a time where the son was
not disagree.
>> Exactly. Right.
>> So that's that's where that's where our
fundamental disagreement is. And so
that's why I'm saying not separate,
distinct.
>> Right. Right. And so I get that part.
And so that's why I'm saying when we say
most high even in your logic in your
order the father is above the son right
>> in what way?
>> In your order like let me break it down
from for my cuz so so I agree that the
son has a lower rank cuz he he submits
himself. He's humble to the father. So
the father the father ranks higher than
him as the source head. Mhm.
>> However, because like what I've been
talking about when it comes to their
essence and nature, they're equal in
their in their essence and their nature.
The father is not superior to the son in
essence.
>> But aren't we supposed to be equal?
>> You and me
>> with God.
>> No, you No, you're not supposed to be
equal with God. Where? Show me. Show me
where the Bible say we supposed to be
equal with God.
>> Yeah. You see, see, give me give me give
me Philippians. It's in Philippians 2
and 6. brother that's not us.
>> When he said yes it is.
>> He says that's talking about Christ. It
says even though he was in the form of
God did not robbery to be evil.
>> So it's talking about how humble Christ
was not
>> no but okay in in verse five pull verse
five of that very verse.
>> Quote verse five.
>> Um
>> have this mind in you.
>> Have this mind in you. Right.
>> Which was also in Christ Jesus. Talking
about
>> So who are supposed what mindset are we
supposed to have?
>> A humble mindset. We we supposed to have
the He said, "Let this mind be in you,"
>> which was also in
>> Mashiach Yahawashi. Who I say that
[laughter] I say that cuz my audience
listen reason why I say Mashiach
Yahawasha, right? [laughter] Cuz my
audience ain't going to be like, "Hey,
Capman, you weren't saying his name in
Hebrew. He was on the stage. You say it
in Hebrew.
>> You can return to them, Rebecca." But he
he becomes all things to all people.
[laughter] You know what I'm saying?
LOOK, YOU COME ON, MAN. I got you. I got
you, man.
>> So now, so in Philippians 2:5, Paul is
saying, "Let this mind be in you, which
was also in Yahawashi."
>> What mind? What? What mind?
>> Yahawashi's mind.
>> No, no, no. So look what you know, you
know what the context is about, right,
Cal?
>> Yes.
>> So talking about humility and not
thinking of oneself as above the other,
right? Absolutely. Let's just read a few
just for the audience sake. Um, so it
says, "So if there is any encouragement
in Christ, any comfort from love, any
participation in the spirit, any
affection and sympathy, complete my joy
by being of the same mind, having the
same love, being full, being in full
accord and of one mind. Do nothing from
selfish ambition or conceit,
>> but in humility count others more
significant than yourselves. Let each of
you look not only to his own interests
but also to the interests of others. So
that's the mindset that he's that he's
that he's laying ground for like so then
he goes on to say um have this mind
among yourselves
>> which was also in Christ Jesus. So he
said this is Christ had this mind.
>> So we would agree Christ is not saying
what we're reading. This is Paul saying
what we're reading. Yeah. We agree. Yep.
>> Right. Okay. Good.
>> Yeah. So, so have this the what's the
mindset by humbling yourself, not
putting yourself above others,
>> um not looking to your own
self-interest, not being conceited.
That's the mindset. Then he goes in and
says,
>> "Have this mind among yourself." What'
you just pull up?
>> Scriptures.
>> Is that the uh
>> This KJ? So, I got a Z4 and I got a
iPhone.
>> Oh, nice. You you going
>> Yeah. So, this look this three apps at
the same time. That's one at one at one
at right there. Three apps.
>> Yeah, that's no sweat.
>> Yeah.
>> Have this mind among yourselves with
which is yours in Christ Jesus who
though he was
>> in the form of God. Not us. They ain't
talking about he talking about Christ
now. Right. Right.
>> Right.
>> Okay. though he was in the form of God,
did not did not count equality with God
a thing to be grasped, something to hold
on to, but emptied himself by taking on
the form of a servant and being born in
the likeness of men.
>> So when Paul writes that, he says
clearly this mind state that Yahawashi
had
>> is the same mind state we're supposed to
have. So when I said the whole equal
with God is this mind state, the mind
state that we supposed to have is to not
think that we can't go out there and
with love and with comfort and
fellowship with the spirit and with joy
and likeminded and do all the things
that Christ said. Christ said greater
works we would have over him. Excuse me.
We would do greater works than him.
>> This makes me worry about you.
>> No, don't worry about me. So if they're
saying that we have to have that mind
state, we can't make Christ be the
father because he never said he was the
father.
>> He embodied doing
>> nobody believes he's the father.
>> That's not our argument. You know,
that's not my argument.
>> See, now this might be a good reason why
we're sitting together.
>> For us in our world, when you say Jesus,
I'm going use your language now. when
you become all men all
>> well you say Jesus is the most high for
us you are saying he's the father
>> I know I know
>> right and so that's the problem that we
have and when like that's why I said
earlier if you have a debate and you say
Jesus is God Jesus is God Jesus is God
we not going to argue because we can see
in Exodus 71 uh Moses being called God
by God you can see in other scriptures I
said ye gods you see Christ echo those
same sentiments so the word God doesn't
bother us. But when you say the most
high God, that's where we draw the line
because the father is the only one. Like
in Psalms 83 in the last verse, it says
that thou whose name alone is Yahawah
art the most high over all the earth.
Let's talk about it says alone.
>> All right. So let's talk about this. So
right, you know, I don't believe Jesus
is the father. You know that, right?
>> I do when you say it, but I don't when
you explain it.
>> Okay, fair enough. That's fair. So I
believe
Jesus and the father are two distinct
persons. They talk to each other. Jesus
humbles himself to the father. The
father sends the son. The son sends the
spirit from the father. I don't believe
they're the same person.
>> So why do you debate us then?
>> Because why do you even debate us then
if you don't believe they the same
person? HE JUST SAID THEY not the same
person.
>> Cuz here's the part. Cuz that's the only
thing y'all got right. The only thing
y'all got right is that Jesus and is not
the father. THAT'S ALL Y'ALL GOT RIGHT.
>> WHAT WE GOT WRONG? THAT THAT'S OUR WHOLE
BASIS.
>> The next part that you get wrong, what's
the next part? What part we get wrong?
>> Is the essence of Christ.
>> You get it? You believe that Jesus is a
cre is a creature created by the father
who came into existence at some